INDICATION OF HOW BRUTAL ISIS
CAN BE EVEN WITHIN ITS OWN
RANKS.
CRAWLING THROUGH SIMULATED
BARBED WIRE.
THE LAST MAN GETS THE HONOR OF A
KNEE TO THE BODY, A FIGHTER
DRAGS A CLOTH MAT TO RESCUE A
WOUNDED COMRADE.
AS THEY PULL AWAY, THEY'RE FIRED
AT.
THIS IS THE LATEST ISIS
PROPAGANDA, A VIDEO CALLED
"BLOOD OF JIHAD" SHOWING
FIGHTERS IN BASIC TRAINING.
IS THIS ANYTHING THAT THEY WOULD
USE IN ANBAR RIGHT NOW ANYWHERE
ON THE BATTLEFIELD?
>> ALMOST NEVER.
THIS TYPE OF HAND-TO-HAND
FIGHTING WITH AUTOMATIC WEAPONS,
MORTARS, ARTILLERY, VEHICLES,
ALMOST NEVER REALLY OCCURS.
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE VIDEO,
WHAT YOU HAVE IS THE STAGE SET
OF EXERCISES.
YOU LOOK AT THEM AND THIS REALLY
ISN'T A TRAINING EXERCISE.
IT'S A VIDEO EXERCISE.
>> Reporter: PROPAGANDA?
>> EXACTLY.
>> Reporter: BUT SOMEHOW ISIS
HAS CAPTURED MOST OF ANBAR
PROVINCE AND COME WITHIN JUST A
FEW MILES OF BAGHDAD
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT.
WHAT TACTICS HAVE THEY DEPLOYED?
ON THE BATTLEFIELD, ISIS HAS
PREVIOUSLY USED WHAT IS CALLED A
REACT TO CONTACT DRILL.
THAT MEANS IN A FIREFIGHT THEY
MAKE INITIAL CONTACT AGAINST
THEIR ENEMY USING THE SMALLEST
NUMBER OF FIGHTERS POSSIBLE,
MAYBE THREE OR FOUR.
>> AND THEN PUT DOWN FIRE,
BECAUSE THOSE THREE OR FOUR GUYS
CAN KEEP 20, 30 OF THE ENEMY
FOCUSED ON THEM.
>> Reporter: THEN A LARGER GROUP
OF ISIS FIGHTERS COMES AROUND,
FLANKING THE ENEMY ON ONE SIDE,
FINDS A WEAKNESS, ATTACKS IT.
>> THIS IS SOMETHING THE U.S.
ARMY RANGER REGIMENT WAS
PRACTICED FOR YEAR.
>> Reporter: IN ANBAR, ANALYSTS
SAY THEY'VE SHIFTED TACTICS.
ISIS SURROUNDS OUTPOSTS WITH FEW
IRAQI SOLDIERS IN AND LAUNCHES
NONCONVENTIONAL ASSAULTS.
>> IT'S A COMBINATION OF
TERRORISM.
IT IS THE USE OF INDIRECT FIRE
TO SOFTEN UP POSITIONS.
IT'S TO ASSAULT KEY POSITIONS
WITH SUICIDE